The Joe Rogan Experience that [__]
vehicle that you have built is the most
ridiculous thing I've ever been inside
in my life I can't believe how fast it
is like we only did the speed limit
today right yeah but we got there very
quick we got there very quickly yes
1817 horsepower and uh 3 000 pounds so
you got some power weight ratio to work
with there that's like 700 more
horsepower than a Tesla plaid yeah it's
like taking a McLaren 765lt and adding a
thousand horsepower to it
something nobody needs but we've sold 36
of those the Venom F5 what is that what
happened to you in your life that you
needed to make these Preposterous cars
well you know like what what is going on
yeah
how did you get to be this guy like what
did uh how did this start out where you
you're making these 1800 horsepower it's
probably kind of like you know the pool
hall deal when we were younger like I
didn't have a good relationship with my
old man he was a car guy but we didn't
get along
and I don't know maybe 60 years later
you know I'm 60 now I've got you know I
still feel like I got a little chip on
my shoulder or something to prove maybe
a little bit less now but but for sure
isn't it interesting that you would
never want that to your for your son no
but boy is that a great motivating
factor oh for sure for sure yeah I'd
live up you know grow up in a kind of an
abusive situation and neglect and uh you
know now all of a sudden I've got all
this motivation I've had all this
motivation for the last you know 40
Years of my business career so it's been
good it's funny because you would never
want that for your children no I mean
it's amazing how well it's worked out
for people like you or for me yeah I
mean I I you know I don't think
everybody out there that has some level
of success has not necessarily been
abused and motivated by negativity but I
can definitely see with our five kids
with the nurture mainly from my wife
hope they're going to turn out just fine
and they'll be plenty successful but you
know that's just I don't know your story
but that's that's my that's my road now
I got here it can lead you to be very
ambitious and very successful but it can
also just [__] your life up oh sure and
you can be very ambitious and very
successful and also be like happy like
that's absolutely that's possible too
yeah you don't have to have a tortured
childhood for sure no very very blessed
I mean you know to have an opportunity
to build toys for people you know
whether it's a you know a seven eight
hundred thousand horsepower pickup truck
or a Venom F5 uh you know we're talking
earlier is about first world problems
right yeah something nobody really needs
Nobody Needs to Go to comedy show or MMA
but they do it for entertainment I tell
people all the time we're more and
there's Stars up there yeah why am I
running a little Choice
after the Rick for flare gummy bear and
they're going to really start flying
yeah yeah so uh now feel very blessed
and we're definitely uh you know people
come to us because they want to
entertain themselves with their vehicles
that's a great way of looking at it too
because that's really what those kind of
cars are like when I try to describe my
love of old muscle cars for people
because you know they kind of are not
super reliable yeah they're not so great
at handling sure and you know so I turn
them I get them done into Resto mods but
still they're but when I drive them the
experience is entertaining it's like a
ride like I'm not just in a Corolla I'm
not just in some quiet Subaru I'm gonna
ride but does it take like when you
drive your Land Cruiser you drive you
know one of your older cars does it take
you back to that time either when you
had that car you aspire to have that car
you knew the guy or the girl that had
that car kind of growing up and you
wanted it back then but you didn't know
how you're going to get it oh yeah for
sure with my Chevelle definitely because
my Chevelle
I have a 1970s uh black with the White
Stripes The Tuxedo Chevelle sure
what's that you got the calendar on the
hood yeah well it actually is uh a 454
under the hood and uh Colvin Casey
colvin's you know yeah okay big Viper
guy yeah [__] love that dude yeah he
hooked up the cow so that it when the
ignition those vacuum hoses that get old
and crack and yeah it's uh when I was a
kid when I was about 16 years old one of
my friends picked me up his friend had a
1970 Chevelle we were going somewhere
and uh I just remember getting in the
backseat of the car going how is it
possible that this kid owns this car
yeah this is crazy yeah it was the best
looking car I'd ever seen in my life